Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This will be my Shazam
Fury of the Gods Post Credits Scene Video.
There's a whole bunch
Easter eggs and references.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
and careful for spoilers
for the end of the movie
if you haven't seen it yet
because we have to talk about everything.
At the end of the movie,
Shazam sacrifices himself to stop Kalypso
and return everything to normal on planet
Earth.
He's successful, but he's dead.
So when they go back to the God realm,
this alternate dimension,
they treat it like an alternate dimension.
They bury him in the ground
and we get a big cameo from Gal Gadot's
Wonder Woman who comes back to reignite
the God spark
inside the staff of the Wizard Shazam,
or the staff of Atlas.
Once she reactivates the staff,
the Wizard can use it to bring Billie back
to life and restore
life to the giant tree in this dimension.
The whole idea is that the tree generates
this magical feel which also gives back
most of the gods their powers.
He comes out of the ground in Shazam form.
He'd been turned back into Billy
after he lost his powers and died,
he jokes about them burying him
in the ground after only 2 minutes
because it's only been a couple of minutes
since the Post Credits scene,
even though much longer
had passed in universe.
Like it's only been a couple of minutes
since we saw that part of the movie
where he died.
He sees Wonder Woman is there
and they pay off
all the jokes from earlier in the movie
about him really liking Wonder Woman
and wanting to go out with her,
wanting to make out with her.
This is in the promo
that Warner Brothers released publicly.
She jokes to him, Just worry
about saving the world, kid, and walks
away smiling and he's like,
Please call me sometime, guys.
Stick to saving the world.
Kid Wonder Woman also tells them
to use the power of her father,
Zuse wisely, which is a big payoff
on the source of all their power,
because one of the powers
he has is the power of Zuse,
which is where his lightning bolts
come from.
They're meant to be
the exact same type of lightning bolts,
the same exact energy that Zuse had.
Wonder Woman is a demigod.
She is the daughter of Zuse
in the DCU too, so that qualifies her
as a god in the DCU,
even though she's a demigod.
Technically
they end the movie back at their house.
They're all having dinner.
Anthea says that she's also going to spend
time on earth with Freddie Freeman.
Like they're going to be going out
as a couple now.
It'll just be enjoying life amongst
humans, learning more about human culture.
The Wizard Shazam comes back
and says that he's going to keep the staff
for a good long while. They're like,
I'll just keep it with me too.
So nothing
bad winds up happening. Is this it?
He's been in prison
in the alternate dimension of the God
realm for so long that just going to spend
time traveling the earth
over the credits they play Elvis little
less conversation in the reference here
if you're not a big Elvis fan, is that
Elvis in real life when he was growing
up, was a huge fan of Captain Marvel
Jr Freddie Freeman's character.
So we modeled his entire
look like the whole vibe
from Captain Marvel Junior,
which they joke about during the movie.
When Freddie calls Billy Captain
Every Powers Junior.
That's why Elvis use
the lightning bolt on his taking care
of business pendant that he always wore
and why one of his jumpsuits
was blue like this.
Like Freddie Freeman's classic costume.
You have to remember this.
This is all happening
a long time ago in the golden age,
when Elvis was still very young.
That's what all the Captain
Marvel characters are.
But in the first Post Credits scene,
we see John economists Steven Agee and
Amelia Harcourt, Jennifer Holland,
who's now married to James Gunn,
who is now the Kevin Foggy of DC Studios,
showing up after the events of Peacemaker
Season one and the Suicide Squad movie,
Although she was in the Black Adam movie
recently show up on Amanda Waller's orders
to recruit Shazam to the Justice Society,
and they mostly play it for laughs
as a joke
to follow up on the whole obsession
that he has with Wonder Woman and
being a joke on the Justice League name.
Also making some Avengers
Marvel references too, because James Gunn
just came from the Marvel movies.
John Economists and Amelia Harcourt start
the scene walking to a remote location
outside Philadelphia in the woods with him
complaining about his feet hurting.
She makes fun of him for his shoes.
That's a follow up on the way
that everybody always
cloud on John Economist
during Peacemaker Season
one for being so pathetic,
like dyeing his hair.
They complain back and forth
with each other about scaring Billie off
and Amanda Waller telling them
that Shazam was super powerful,
but he was kind of immature,
so don't scare him off.
He could be a huge asset to the team.
That's a joke about him still being Billy.
He's immature
because he's still literally a little kid,
despite the fact
he's about to turn 18 during the movie,
which in the United States
is technically called The Age of majority,
where the law considers
someone to be an adult
and you can legally sign contracts
yourself, you don't need your parent's
permission to do anything
when they arrive at a rundown shack.
Their words speedy on the side here,
even though it's
meant to be this old timey gas station,
this has been abandoned for a while.
It's a reference to his super speed,
which he references
several times in the movies.
Also referencing
the flash, like there was another guy
with a red suit
and a lightning bolt on it.
That's way faster than me and way better,
which is Canon.
The Flash is meant to be faster
than pretty much all the other characters
in the DC universe that have some form
of super speed like Superman and Shazam.
Shazam!
Speed is about the same as Superman's
because the way their superspeed works
is that it's more like a function
of their super strength.
Whereas the Flash uses the speed force,
which allows them to break
a lot of the natural laws of physics
when they arrive.
He's been waiting for them killing time
by having fun using his lightning bolts
to burst more bottles and soda machines,
which is a callback to the Dr.
Pepper joke in the first movie
where he was using his powers,
do all kinds of fun stuff
and gets them a bunch of free soda.
I hope they pay off this joke in future
movies with him going up against the Dr.
Pepper, people like Dr.
Pepper versus Shazam, it's like he's
got some vendetta against Dr.
Pepper, always blowing up Dr.
Pepper cans when they introduce themselves
and say they're here to recruit him
for a special team.
They play it for another Wonder Woman
Justice League joke
where they only get half the sentence out.
The word justice in Shazam
freak saying yes a thousand times.
Yes, because he wants to be
on the Justice League so bad.
A thousand times. Yes.
They finish the sentence
saying Society, justice, society.
And it's almost like the ear
being led out of a balloon.
Billy gets super pissed off at them, like,
Wait a second, aren't
you here to recruit me to the team
with Wonder Woman?
I just want to be on the one
with Wonder Woman.
And she's like, No, we're the other team.
We're like the B team.
He goes on and on
about wanting to be with Wonder Woman.
John Economides makes fun of him for that.
Why are you so obsessed
with Wonder Woman dude?
And he starts arguing with them
about how the name Justice
Society is stupid because it's too similar
to the Justice League name.
Like, why would you name your team
something just like the other team,
even though they have no association
with each other,
which is more of a joke
on the classic comics naming convention
because the Golden Age comics
is where the Justice Society came from.
Then, many years later,
during the Silver Age of Comics,
they created the Justice League
with a bunch of different characters.
And it wasn't
till the modern age of comics like years
after that that younger comic book
artists tried to reconcile that back story
and continuity.
They also make jokes
about the naming conventions
between Golden Age and Silver Age
and all the continuity issues.
Earlier in the film,
when Freddie Freeman starts coming up
with all the different names,
like I think we can come up
with a better name.
He calls himself Captain Every Powers,
which is a play on Captain
Marvel,
the original Shazam name from the comics.
Originally it was just the wizard
that was called Shazam.
Billy was called Captain Marvel
when he got his powers in.
When Freddie Freeman calls
Billy Captain Every Powers Junior.
That's a play on Freddie
Freeman's original comic book name,
which was just Captain Marvel Junior in.
The funny thing is, David Sandberg,
the director, actually revealed
that during this Post Credits scene,
they were actually supposed
to have the Justice Society themselves
show up to recruit
Billy Shazam for the team.
But there was some fiasco that happened
behind the scenes long before James
Gunn was hired for DC.
This happened really early in the process
when they were still filming the movie,
so their backup
idea was to use the Peacemaker characters
to accomplish the exact same scene,
but it was going to play out
relatively dissimilar way.
But you would have had Hawkman
and the other Justice
Society characters here talking to Billy
had it have been their characters,
they also probably would have had
more of a play on Billy
not recognizing them like,
Wait a minute, Hawkman,
you're not on the Justice League.
I thought you were here to recruit me
for the Justice League.
Shazam did join the Justice Society
during JSA
number 37,
but that wasn't until 2000 to black.
Adam in the comics had a longer history
with the Justice Society, and they just
introduced the Live Action Justice Society
during the Black Adam movie.
Even though there's all these questions
about the James Gunn reboot
Who's Coming Back?
What's the Justice Society
roster going to be when they come back?
But the fact that they didn't change this
post credits scene in the movie
makes it sound like James Gunn
does intend on eventually paying this off.
But the fact that they're recruiting him
for the Justice Society
and not the Justice League, I think
is them just saying that if Zachary Levi
Shazam comes back, he will not be on that
first Justice League roster
when they do a new version of the Justice
League movie with a new roster
of characters at the end of DC,
Chapter one Gods and Monsters.
Then Billy makes a bunch of jokes
about the alternate names
for the Justice Society,
which would be better.
He mentions the Authority Society,
which is a reference to the authority
movie that James Gunn is doing during DC.
Chapter one.
There are Wildstorm teams that they're
bringing to the main DCU live action,
continuity, the codes Society, he
mentions, isn't a reference to anything,
but then he drops a big Marvel reference
saying The Avengers Society like, Ooh,
I like that name. For some reason,
I like that.
James Gunn literally just came
from the Marvel Universe, Guardians
of the Galaxy three to become
the new Kevin Feige of DC movies.
Then they get to the second Post Credits
scene where Dr.
Sivana and Mr.
Mind.
It's been two years
since the events of the first Shazam
Post Credits scene
with both of those characters and Dr.
Sivana going into prison,
which he jokes about.
The camera zooms in on the drawings
that he's done, the wall killing Shazam.
He's got this long beard in Mr.
Mind, who's voiced by the director,
David Sandberg himself,
who also had another onscreen
cameo earlier in the movie
as one of the random citizens
killed by the monsters after they escaped,
Savannah complains to Mr.
Mine, asking him where he's been
for the last two years in Mr.
Mind jokes that it takes some time
to set plans in motion,
which is also meant to be a joke
about how long it's taken for them
to pay off the last post credits scene.
Like, when are you actually going
to pay off this scene?
You set up all these big plans.
We haven't heard about since then with him
yelling at Dr.
Savannah to be patient.
He's almost completed everything that he's
needed to do to set things in motion
inserts, joking that eventually he'll be
able to fly, he'll be able to walk around,
he'll be much bigger,
which is another reference to Mr.
Might in the comics in his original plan
to conquer the seven realms of magic,
making him nigh invincible,
controlling all magic in the universe,
which is right out of the comics.
And it's part of that post credits
scene from the first Shazam movie
where he mentions that like
the Seven Realms, the magic will be his,
the seven realms are bound to be powers
in the comics. Mr.
Mind eventually evolves
into his final boss form
where he's huge, like his giant size.
He has wings
and he can move around really fast.
So the idea is that instead of Shazam
versus Black Adam
in a potential third movie,
these Shazam characters,
should they continue in a third movie
or come back, they'll cover the Mr.
Mind seven Realms of Magic storyline.
The funny thing about that, though,
is that Black
Adam is a big part of that storyline.
He winds up teaming up with Shazam
to stop Mr.
Mind, but the Rock had a huge
falling out with DC
after James
Gunn was hired as the new president.
It sounds like he's
not coming back to DC at all,
so when Black Adam comes back,
it'll be a completely different actor.
And we also found out that the Shazam
people offered the Rock
a black Adam cameo scene during Shazam
Fury of the Gods, and he turned it down.
So the way they're ending these
post credits scenes and setting up him,
joining the Justice Society and then doing
the seven realms of magic storyline,
they want to let you know that they could
continue this storyline in future movies.
James Gunn is relatively open about that.
Like it could wind up happening,
but a lot of that just depends, according
to the DC people
on the box office for the movie,
if he spotted any other references
or Easter eggs in the post credits scenes
that it didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments
and let me know when they do eventually
bring the Shazam characters back.
Black Adam Character back.
Who do you want to be playing
those characters?
Do you want to see these ones come back
or do you want them to just recast?
I'm working on my full breakdown
at East Race for the entire movie.
I'll talk more about Wonder
Woman in all this and what the future of
the Shazam characters are in the DC
chapter one Gods and Monsters.
Everyone click here for that Shazam
Fury of the Gods Wonder Woman scene
and click here
for my Justice League Dark Side Trailer
that Zack Snyder just released.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.